thank you very much and there's just
about five minutes between my welcome to
you and senator Sanders so thank you so
much for being here
I am Malu Harrison and it's truly a
pleasure to welcome you here to Miami
Book Fair this book fair would not be
possible without the support of many
many sponsors such as a knight
Foundation OHL at Ayano to the groud
Foundation the Batchelor foundation and
many many other sponsors as I said we
also are very grateful to the Friends of
Miami Book Fair International if you
would wave one more time because I'd
like to recognize you for your support
and of course miami-dade College the
convener of this outstanding literary
gathering where so many students yes
let's applaud
[Applause]
so many miami-dade college students
faculty and staff give of themselves on
the volunteer in various aspects of this
fair to make it what it is so thank you
to miami-dade College as well you will
be able to purchase your own book
senator Sanders book immediately outside
of this room so please take advantage of
that following the presentation but
without further ado I'd like to bring on
someone who will make the formal
introduction this evening and he's none
other than Ronald Goldfarb mr. Goldfarb
wears many many hats
he's a Washington lawyer he's also the
author of 11 plus books while serving as
a literary agent for over a hundred
authors including senator Sanders mr.
Goldfarb has served in the Kennedy
administration a special assistant and I
could go on and on in terms of his many
contributions to civic life to the legal
affairs of this nation and to society
overall he lives now in Key Biscayne but
travels frequently between Key Biscayne
and Washington DC please help me welcome
Ronald Goldfarb thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I know you haven't come here
to see me so I'm going to do something
that's very difficult for Washington
lawyers I'm going to speak very very
briefly before the election I thought my
role was to kind of warm up the house
with some witty remarks like mentioning
how Bernie does a terrific imitation of
Larry David and how a better storyline
for the election would have been poor
kid from Brooklyn whoops rich kid from
Queens
[Applause]
[Music]
but after the election a week ago I
decided that Ryan Witte doesn't work and
I've tossed those notes away because I
know you all understand as I do that
we're in a very frightening political
season Bob Dylan's line came back to me
it's not dark yet
but it's getting there that said our
speaker tonight does offer an individual
ray of life with no money no
organization two years ago but with good
ideas and an integrity that shines
through as you'll see in his words he
won 22 states including I would add
Wisconsin and Michigan
[Applause]
thirteen and a half million votes 46% of
the delegates 2.8 million donors who
gave small amounts of money but great
passion for his campaign and most
interesting to me is that 70% of the
people who voted in the election on the
Democratic side voted for Bernie Sanders
in that group that that group is growing
to be the largest group of voters in the
country and here's something that you
probably don't know while I was driving
on a bus to a airport after Bernie's
book was sold I got a call from one of
st. Martin's colleagues in their
business holt a publisher of books for
teenagers 14 to 19 year olds and she
said we would love to adapt
Bernie's book for our audience and that
is going to happen to
so I think it's a kick for an 80 83
year-old book lover to help a 74 year
old politician make that visionary lead
on a new generation of voters and I just
want to add with one one last anecdote
and that is I happen to be watching Wolf
Blitzer a few days ago interviewing the
indomitable Jane Sanders and he trying
to make go ahead see this over wolf
trying to make a story where there
wasn't one said well you're you've done
so well in the election and your book is
a best-seller does that mean your
husband's going to run in 2020
Jane's answer was wrong question Woolf
asked me that in 2019 we should be
talking about 2017
so I'm very honored now as they say in
this as his colleague saying the Senate
I'm gonna yield my table to the great
senator from Vermont who's going to tell
us all what he will be and we should be
doing in 2017 the great Bernie Sanders
thank you
thank you all
thank you all for coming out
thank you well as I think many of you
have have heard me say a million times
this is not about Bernie it is about you
and us let me thank you all for coming
out let me thank miami-dade College for
hosting the event and bran gulp offer is
very generous introduction I want to
talk obviously about the book but I
suspect there are one or two other
things on your mind so we'll talk about
that as well
all right let's get going point number
one Hillary Clinton ended up getting a
million and a half more votes than
Donald Trump don't forget about that so
if anyone tells you that mr. Trump has a
mandate to go forward with some of his
very reactionary ideas tell them that he
lost the popular vote by a million and a
half votes number two and this is also
important I just want all of you to
understand that I've been around this
country I've been in this business for a
while what I'm telling you is the truth
on virtually not all but on virtually
every major issue facing this country
whether it is raising the minimum wage
to a living wage whether it is pay
equity for women who are now making 79
cents on the dollar compared to men
where is whether it is creating millions
of decent-paying jobs by rebuilding our
crumbling infrastructure whether it is
criminal justice reform immigration
reform on all of those issues and many
more campaign finance reform on all of
those issues guess what this majority of
the American people are on our side
[Applause]
and when somebody goes and tells you
that Republicans have some kind of
mandate to cut Social Security and
Medicare and Medicaid or to give tax
breaks to billionaires or to ignore the
scientific overwhelming scientific
evidence regarding climate change tell
your friends who tell you that they are
dead wrong now let me just suggest to
you why I think Trump did as well as he
did and then suggest to you in a very
broad sense where I think we have to go
then we get into the book what is going
on in this country in terms of the pain
that many people are feeling is not
reported in the media and it is not
dealt with in the halls of Congress it's
a funny thing in the book you'll notice
there's a chapter where I talk about the
corporate media something I'll talk a
little bit about tonight and it turns
out and I say this not being you know
bragging here it turns out somebody did
a study and they said that over the
course I think it was of the year 2/3 of
the discussion on Sunday morning new
shows about poverty was from Bernie
Sanders the point is not me the point is
where the hell is everybody else I mean
how do you
[Applause]
so what you have in our country today is
a lot of pain and a lot of suffering
that we don't talk about in the Congress
with few exceptions that certainly never
on NBC or CBS or the media and you got
millions of people out there who are
saying to themselves who hears my pain
who knows that I am alive who gives a
damn about me and one of the reasons
that I'm going to do everything that I
can to reform the Democratic Party is
that I want the Democratic Party to hear
stop pain
and I want to just run through I want
you just to follow me for a second let's
think about it right now in Miami right
now in Burlington Vermont there are
single moms go to work they need good
quality childcare they make forty fifty
thousand dollars a year maybe or maybe
less but childcare costs ten or fifteen
thousand dollars how do you have decent
quality childcare if it costs 15 or 20
thousand dollars a year and you're
making fifty thousand dollars a year or
less who talks about that issue seen it
lately on NBC or CBS see politicians
talking about it no you don't we are the
only major country on earth not to
guarantee health care to all people as a
right
today in America despite the gains of
the Affordable Care Act twenty eight
million people have no health insurance
at all and many of you and tens of
millions of Americans who do have health
insurance have deductibles and
co-payments that are so high that you
don't go to the doctor when you should
and then we see thousands of people
dying every single year because they
walk into the doctor's office when it is
too late and the doctor says why didn't
you come in six months or a year before
when you first got your symptom and the
person says I didn't have any insurance
or I couldn't afford the deductible we
lose thousands of people every single
year right now in America one out of
five people who goes to a doctor's
office because they are sick and they
get a prescription you know what one out
of those five people cannot afford to
fill the prescription elderly people
here in Miami in Vermont all over the
country you know what they do they cut
their prescription pills in half which
is a bad thing to do because they can't
afford the medicine they need and every
day
drug companies are jacking up the price
for one reason alone because they can
get
away with that who is hearing who is
paying attention to the people who can't
afford the medicine they desperately
need let me tell you a story about how
corrupt the system is I was out in
California a couple of weeks ago working
on a proposition there called
proposition 61 most of you don't know it
what it was was an effort on the part of
the people of California to lower the
costs of prescription drugs in their
state anyone want to take a guess as to
how much money the pharmaceutical
industry spent in opposition to that
proposition to take a guess now I'm not
a billion [ __ ] Oh a hundred and thirty 1
million dollars 48 as I understand that
47 48 percent of the people voted for it
it lost after the industry spent a
hundred and thirty 1 million dollars and
that raises not only the issue of the
high cost of prescription drugs what
else was a raise it raises the issue of
campaign finance reform and how we're
going to bring about any change in this
country when the drug companies and the
insurance companies and the Koch
brothers and other billionaires are able
to spend unlimited sums of money when
Donald Trump talks about taking on the
establishment there are workers out
there who are making nine 10 bucks an
hour who listen to him and he said he's
going to raise their wages and they're
making 10 bucks an hour you cannot live
on 10 bucks an hour almost half of the
older workers in America people 55 or
older have no money in the bank for when
they retire you got that you're 55 was
60 you're going to retire in five years
you got no money in the bank you're
getting sick you need health care how
you going to retire with no money to
make millions of people scared to death
about going into retirement you've got
young people today bright young people
who do well in high school
they can't even afford to go to college
any others leaving college forty fifty
sixty thousand dollars in debt and
they're making 12 $14 an hour and they
don't know how they're going to be able
to pay off that debt I was in during the
course of the campaign one of the things
that I did in the book was I talked
about some of the places that I went to
when I tried to go to places that other
candidates often don't go and I went to
a County in West Virginia called
McDowell County it's in the southern
part of West Virginia and in that County
and in counties all over that state in
Kentucky and elsewhere turns out that
people today unbelievably are now dying
at a younger age than their parents the
whole drift of modern society in America
and around the world is as a result of
public health as a result of medical
breakthroughs and we've seen some great
breakthroughs on cancer other illnesses
people live longer lives there are
millions of Americans today in various
parts of this country working-class
people who are dying at a younger age
than their parents they are dying as a
result of drug addiction of alcoholism
and of suicide in other words the
despair is so great among people who are
trying to get by and nine ten bucks an
hour they're worried about the kids they
are going nowhere and life overcomes
them and they turn to drugs and alcohol
and suicide and Donald Trump said I know
that I went to Pine Ridge Native
American reservation
[Applause]
because I tried to focus some attention
on the place on the tragedy that faces
many Native American communities
throughout our country people have been
lied to people have been cheated people
have been ignored in Pine Ridge in South
Dakota the life expectancy as I
understand it is equivalent to Guatemala
a poor third world countries youth
suicide very high unemployment rampant
domestic abuse terrible I was in
Baltimore Maryland thousands and tens of
thousands of people are addicted to
heroin
and no treatment is available for them I
was in New York City went to the public
housing projects there they have a
backlog of 17 billion dollars to repair
public housing in New York City 17
billion dollars people are living in
dilapidated public housing and on and on
it goes what's my point my point is if
you think that Trump won simply because
everybody who voted for them is a racist
or a sexist or a xenophobe you would be
mistaken yes yes there are those people
who did vote for Trump for those reasons
but I think what Trump managed to tap is
the anger in the frustration that so
many people feel who are ignored who are
forgotten who are suffering and our job
and I will do everything in my power
I've just a few days ago became an
official member of the Democratic
leadership
[Applause]
[Applause]
and that means you know what I intend to
do in that position is to make it very
clear that the Democratic Party cannot
have two masses it cannot bow down to
Wall Street and the drug companies and
corporate America
[Applause]
and then tell the working people of this
country who for the last forty years
have seen a shrinking of the middle
class
millions of whom are working longer
hours for lower wages you can't tell
them that we're on their side when we're
hustling money from Wall Street so the
Democratic Party has got to make it
clear which side it's on and I'm going
to do everything I can to make certain
that it is on the side of the working
families of this country
now during the course of his campaign
and before his campaign Donald Trump has
said and done some horrific things
regarding minorities and immigrants I
want all of you not to forget that
before mr. Trump was even a candidate
for president he was a leader of the
so-called birther movement and do not
mistake for one second what that
so-called birther movement was about it
was a racist attempt to undermine the
legitimacy of the first african-american
president in our history that's what it
was
now you can disagree all you want with
Barack Obama it's called democracy but
it is not acceptable to try to undermine
his legitimacy as Trump did by
suggesting that he was not born in the
United States of America and I hope very
much that mr. Trump who is nobody's fool
I hope very much that he understands the
damage that he has done to our country
internally and around the world not only
with his disrespect to the African
American community but the ugly language
he has used on Mexican Americans his
belief that we should ban people of one
of the largest religions in the world
Muslims from coming into this country
the language that he has used which I
cannot even quote regarding women and
his attitude toward women
[Applause]
now I don't have to tell anybody here
that for hundreds of years from before
this country became a country when the
first settlers came here and treated the
Native American people so horrific Lee
from then through slavery through sexism
through homophobia through the attacks
and prejudice against the Irish and the
Italians and the Jews and every other
nationalities that came here the
struggle for 200 years has been a fight
against discrimination a fight to
paraphrase dr. Martin Luther King jr.
that we judge people not by the color of
their skin but by their character as
human beings that has been the struggle
[Applause]
and when we remember when we remember
that 50 60 years ago african-americans
of the South didn't even have the right
to vote when we remember a hundred years
ago women were not running for president
they didn't have the right to vote they
couldn't get the education or the jobs
they wanted when 30 years ago no time at
all people in the gay community hid
their sexuality because of the
retribution that would occur to them if
they stood up and said that they were
gay we have a right as a nation to be
proud in how far we have come now we got
a long way to go racism sexism
homophobia still exists no question
about it
but we do have a right to be proud that
we have gone a long long way in fighting
all forms of discrimination in fact when
I can tell you without the slightest
hesitancy that the younger generation of
today is the least racist the least
sexist the least homophobic in the
history of this country
and I say all of that I say all of that
because I want you for a moment to
reflect reflect upon those very brave
people who stood up for civil rights
long before Martin Luther King Jr's it
in a way back 100 150 years ago people
are thrown in jail beaten lynched
fighting for justice think about the
women who went on hunger strikes who
went to jail who died demanding that
women not be second-class citizens the
struggle of the gay community etc etc we
have come a long way and what I say to
miss the Trump
we are not going backwards
[Applause]
and you know all of us all of us who
know history understand that it is the
easiest thing in the world for
demagogues to pick on minorities when
people are hurting and in pain it is
very easy to say there is your enemy
some guy who is picking tomatoes here in
Florida making eight bucks an hour
there is your enemy or a little girl who
wears a scarf there is your enemy or
some African American down the street
there is your enemy our job and it is
the job of the majority in this country
to stand with the minorities
[Applause]
and on this issue on this issue there
cannot be compromised we have come too
far we are going to defend human rights
and civil rights and the rights of women
in this country and there is another
area another area which concerns me and
I say all these things because you know
in politics in the Congress people
disagree on education health care we
yell at each other and we argue but some
issues I think we cannot compromise on
it escape you want to give you another
one
and here in Miami I think you are very
well aware of this Donald Trump went
through his campaign because the media
didn't pay much attention to it but when
they did what we did learn is that he
believed that climate change is a hoax I
am a member of the US Senate Committee
on the environment and in that capacity
I have spoken to scientists not only
throughout our country but all over the
world the almost unanimous conclusion of
the scientific community is that climate
change is real it is caused by human
activity and it is already doing
devastating harm in this country and
throughout the world the debate is over
[Applause]
and if we do not get our act together
what the scientists are telling us that
the situation will deteriorate
significantly there will be more
droughts there will be more floods Miami
there will be more rising sea levels and
I think you're beginning to experience
that already
there will be more acidification of the
ocean and the incredible impact that has
on marine life there will be more global
conflict as people fight over limited
natural resources such as water and land
to grow their crops I hope that mr.
Trump understands that it is far more
important to listen to the scientific
community than it is for the fossil fuel
industry
[Applause]
in the Senate and in the house you are
going to find many members standing up
and fighting as hard as we can against
some of the ugly proposals that mr.
Trump raised during the campaign and may
bring forward as president but at the
end of the day in my view and I speak
only for myself we are going to win this
battle not in the halls of Congress
where we're outnumbered we're going to
be we're going to win this battle in
grassroots America and what that means
and this is not rhetoric trust me this
is a fact and something that every
American has got to learn democracy is
not a spectator support every person in
this room is a powerful person if you
choose to exercise your power and your
power is not just voting once every two
years
your power is 365 days a year
[Applause]
and your power is not as I hope occurs
not just running great candidates the
school board and City Council and way on
up but your power is figuring out how
you deal with problems bringing people
together because at the end of the day
when millions of Americans stand on the
side of progress sand on the side of
ending discrimination stand on the side
of workers rights stand on the side of
protecting our environment when we stand
up when we are involved when we fight
back no power on earth not Donald Trump
not the Koch brothers not anybody will
stop us and that is what we have to do
[Applause]
um let me say a few words about the book
which I why I came here in the first
place look the first part of the book
deals with the campaign and those of you
are interested in politics will find it
I think interesting and we talked about
why I decided to run against the
sensible opposition of my wife Jane
who's sitting out here someplace
[Applause]
she being smarter than me said why in
god's name would you want to do this and
by the way one of the things that we
mentioned it in the book that she
worried about and i worried about is
that if we won what would happen the day
after
what would Wall Street do what would
corporate america do would they punish
the american people for having voted for
me probably what would the corporate
media have done think about it but i was
one of her worries and it was a
perceptive worry but unfortunately we
didn't have to worry about that
i wish we would have but we didn't
anyhow we talked about a campaign which
is ron gold flawed mentioned we started
off with virtually nothing i know
something about politics in my own state
of vermont and by the way in the summer
when it gets a little hot here come
visit us you'll find it a bit cooler
where a very beautiful state we're a
small state we have about six hundred
and twenty five thousand people and i
know how to campaign in my own state in
my last election i got 71 percent of the
vote so we know how to do that pretty
well but running for US Senate in
vermont is very different and running
for president of the united states and
we've started off knowing virtually
nothing about how to do that and we
talked about what we learned and how we
progress and what i did you know very
often candidates say when asked if
they're going to run they say well you
know they're talking to people and so
actually that was the case with me what
we did is we went around the country and
i wanted to hear what people said did
people really want a candidacy and a
candidate who was prepared to take on
the economic establishment the political
establishment did they really want that
and as I came around went around the
country again as somebody who was not
very well known at that point uh what I
found in meetings all over the country
hundreds of people were coming out and
yes they were sick and tired of
establishment politics and establishment
economics and that's what I pick up
around the country and finally we
decided you know we would do
and we went forward our and then what we
saw is as we made when you run a
campaigners you can think about it okay
what is what do you do what and we
decided for a number of reasons
that we would make rallies meetings like
this a little bit larger than this often
the the cornerstone of the campaign
because for a variety of reasons when
you you know a lot of politicians use
people like yourselves right now it's
kind of a backdrop because what's
important is the TV cameras say what I'm
saying
you're just the backdrop for the TV
cameras but I don't like that I like
talking to people I like being here I
like looking you in the eye and I like
answering and I like answering questions
and what we found is we run around the
country that more and more people were
coming out and it is a bit of a
mind-blowing experiencing experience
walking out in an arena in Portland
Oregon where the Trail Blazers play the
NBA team and looking at at 28,000 people
and I think there are people outside so
the other thing that we try to do we
understood politically if you run in the
primaries we have a pretty crazy system
in that everybody in politics knows that
the first states are very very important
in the first two states while Iowa first
and then a week later New Hampshire so
what we understood is what every
politician runs for president in the
sense if you do poorly in those states
you kind of get pushed aside and you
don't last very much longer
so we have to focus on Iowa and New
Hampshire and what we did which I loved
very much is I had the opportunity in a
small state like Iowa to go to a hundred
and one rallies and meetings and tell me
just like this meetings exactly like
this all over the state of Iowa and it
ended up that I ended up talking
personally face-to-face with something
like three-quarters of the people who
ended up voting for me in the Democratic
caucus so not
amazing I mean that is old-fashioned
politics that is old-fashioned
grassroots politics where you talk to be
legalize your questions and then they go
out and vote New Hampshire the numbers
weren't quite that large but we talked
to a whole lot of people and we did very
very well and what I point out is that
you know we got off to a good start but
it is hard to do that when you got six
or seven states coming up on the same
day and that became hard for us um the
other point that I would relate to you
and Ron mentioned this as well is to run
a national campaign for president you
need to raise a lot of money there's no
ifs buts and maybes about it and we had
no idea how we were going to raise money
and then suddenly I mean was just
unbelievable from day one through the
internet people started sending in money
blew us away and we ended up we ended up
having 2.8 million separate Emelia
people individuals contributing an
average of $27 a piece to the campaign
and many of those people and the other
thing there was an article in the LA
Times that I read and it was almost
difficult to read it really made you
want to cry is that it turns out that a
majority of the people who contribute to
the campaign the guys studied the
floppity got on the phone turns out what
below median family income they were
poor people they were people getting
unemployment they were old people on
Social Security majority the people were
below the median income level of America
so we've been supported I mean that is a
very humbling experience
[Applause]
you know it is it is one thing to go to
Wall Street and to walk out of a
fundraiser with ten million dollars it
is another thing to get checks of $10
and $15 from people who are on Social
Security so that was just an
extraordinarily gratifying experience um
if you would ask me you know people say
well you know what was you know the most
significant thing in the campaign on a
personal level I'll tell you what it was
it was doing rallies all over the
country and on the end of the campaign
in June the last day was June 7th in
California and five other states we we
spent a lot of time in California
running up and down the state and we
held rallies in very rural areas where
presidential candidates never go and on
a beautiful evening there'd be five ten
thousand people coming out often young
Latino kids African American kids white
kids Native Americans were playing an
active role and you look out at a crowd
of such a diverse audience such a
beautiful young people who have such
hopes for this country that is what
inspired me then and that is what
inspires me today and that is what
should inspire all of you
[Applause]
what I want you to know but I want you
to know election results notwithstanding
there are millions of people in this
country who love this country
passionately who want to see this
country become what we all know it can
become and I had the opportunity a
privilege to actually see and meet with
so many of those people and that is
something that I will live with for the
rest of my life well the first half of
the book deals with the campaign and if
you're interested in politics I think
you'll find it interesting
the second half does something a little
bit different and what it says is how do
we go forward we are the wealthiest
nation in the history of the world
that's what we are today and there is no
excuse for 43 million people living in
poverty no excuse for us having the
highest rate of childhood poverty of
almost any major country on earth no
excuse for having more income and wealth
inequality than any other major country
on earth where the top one-tenth of 1%
now owns as much wealth as the bottom
90% where people in Florida are working
two or three jobs and yet 52 percent of
all new income goes to the top one
percent so what I did in the second half
of the book is I took a hard look at
what I believe are the major issues
facing this country
and working with some other people we
wrote down what we think the future
means in terms of going forward where do
we go from here it's one thing to say
wasn't this too bad but it is another
thing to say okay what do we do so let
me just take a few minutes to talk about
what I consider to be some of the major
issues and one of the goals of our
campaign which I think we pretty much
succeeded in was to force debate on
issues that politicians in general do
not talk about and that the corporate
media almost never talks about
and one of those issues one of those
issues is my field that this country is
moving very rapidly into an oligarchic
form of society now I think most
Americans may not even know what the
word oligarchy means but it is a word
that we better start understanding
because that is exactly where we are
moving toward now what does that mean
what it means is you have a relatively
small numbers small number of very
wealthy people billionaires who
increasingly control not only our
economic life but our political life as
well it means that on Wall Street for
example you have the sixth largest
financial institutions just six that
have assets of some ten trillion dollars
which is equivalent to 58% of the GDP of
the United States of America six
financial institutions which a issue
something like two thirds of our credit
cards and one-third of the mortgages six
financial institutions it means that I
talk about this in a whole chapter that
it turns out you've got six major media
conglomerates in this country Time
Warner and CBS and others that determine
about how ninety percent that control
about 90% of the media in America in
determining what people see here in Reed
when you turn on your TV and you think
you've got a hundred channels out there
and you think maybe a hundred different
companies on them they don't they're
owned by relatively few large
conglomerates which are themselves
controlled by bigger entities the
function of media is not to educate the
American people the function of
corporate media is to make as much money
as it possibly can and I think what we
saw in this last campaign what we saw in
this last
champagne and there are studies that
write about this is that over 90% of the
discussion you saw on television was not
about the issues that impact your lives
it was about political gossip or about
mr. Trump when mrs. Clinton not about
the American people it was about polling
and campaign funds and how much money
people raised terrible things that
people said about each other we need a
media among other things that starts
talking about the real issues facing the
American people not just the candidates
[Applause]
and we have a chapter that talks not
just about oligarchy where we are but
how we end a rigged economy what is a
rigged economy mean it means that over
the last 20-30 years there has been a
massive transfer of wealth in this
country and that transfer has gone from
your pockets from the pockets of the
middle class into the pockets of the top
one-tenth of one percent massive
transfer of wealth and we talk about how
do we create an economy to paraphrase
Pope Francis which is based on moral
principles rather than greed and these
are some of the things that have to be
done we have got to determine as a
principle in our economy that if you
work 40 hours a week you do not live in
poverty that means raising the minimum
wage to a living wage
we raise the minimum wage to a living
wage of $15 an hour millions of people
would be taken out of poverty and would
be able to live lives of dignity
spending time with their kids not under
incredible stress it means that in the
year 2016 when we talk about jobs in the
economy we have got to end the disgrace
of women making 79 cents on the dollar
compared to men
[Applause]
it means when we talk about the economy
that we have to understand that the
unemployment figures you see once a
month come out from the government the
official unemployment rate which
nationally is about 5% is different than
the real unemployment rate in this
country which is over 9% including if
you include people are working part-time
when they want to work full-time or
people on high unemployment areas who
have given up looking for work so you
have in real terms 9% of our population
unemployed and that means we need a
massive jobs program we should be hiring
teachers not firing teachers
[Applause]
we can hire a heck of a lot of people
doing the important work of child care
which today is dysfunctional we should
be rebuilding our crumbling
infrastructure roads bridges water
systems Jane and I during the campaign
were in Flint Michigan and we had one of
the most emotional evenings I think that
we have ever had in our lives and that
is talking to a mom whose daughter had
been gregarious and bright and doing
well in school but after drinking the
lead in the water became a child in
special education who had a hard time
remembering simple things and when you
talk to a mom who had gone through that
it takes a lot out of you
but it is not just Flint Michigan that
are struggling with clean water there
are hundreds of communities all over
this country including some in my own
state of Vermont point is that in
America we once had the best
cutting-edge infrastructure in the world
the best bridges the best roads
strongest rail system best levees best
dams that is no longer the case by
heavily investing in our infrastructure
we can create millions of good-paying
jobs and that is exactly what we have to
do when we talk about the economy common
sense tells us all and we hear it an
excellent Community College it tells us
that if we are going to compete
effectively in a highly competitive
global economy we need to have the best
educated workforce in the world
[Applause]
you know that's kind of a no-brainer and
you know what we once did the book goes
into that I think it's 30 years ago we
had a higher percentage of college
graduates or people who attended college
any other country on earth that is no
longer the case we are way down in the
gap between US and other countries is
growing wider now how do you have a
workforce that can handle new jobs which
require a lot of Technology and advanced
learning how do you have a workforce
that can do those things if we have
hundreds of thousands of bright young
people who can't even afford to go to
college and others who are leaving
school deeply in debt so what the book
talks about is the need to get our
national priorities right which says
that billionaires like Donald Trump and
his friends should stop paying their
fair share of taxes
that corporations profitable
corporations making billions a year in
profit should no longer be able to stash
their profits in the Cayman Islands or
Bermuda and not pay a nickel in federal
taxes that Wall Street speculation
should be taxed and that when you do
that you suddenly find that you do have
the money you need to make public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and two substantially lower the burden
of student debt on millions of people
today are in trouble so what the book
says is you know kind of common sensical
who is going to argue against the fact
that we need a well-educated workforce
if we are going to succeed as an economy
and as a nation hard to argue who will
argue that the cost of college is
unaffordable for so many people who will
argue that millions of our people when
they leave school in fifty thousand
dollar debt hundred thousand dollar debt
go to graduate school medical school
three hundred thousand dollar debt who
will argue that that is not insane that
we should be encouraging people to get
the education they need not discouraging
people
again this is just common sense I mean
you think about everyone nods their head
but we don't talk about it enough so the
question then how do you make college
affordable how do you make public
colleges and universities tuition-free
there is a program out there that I
played an active role in expanding it's
called the National Health Service Corps
very few people have heard of that
anyone here heard the National Health
Service call okay good it's a great
program and what it says and we got
billions into it what it says is if you
are a doctor a dentist you have a
problem with affordable dentistry here
in Florida okay it's a big problem in my
sleep but if you're a doctor a dentist
the psychologist the nurse if you are
prepared when you graduate school to
serve in a medically underserved area
the government will forgive your student
debt and that works the program that
works very very well I think we should
expand that concept to say that at a
time when we desperately need good
teachers and childcare workers people in
law enforcement that if you are prepared
to serve in the public we will forgive
your debt
[Applause]
book talks about another issue that you
will hear very little discussion about
in the media or in the halls of Congress
simple question how many major countries
on earth do not guarantee health care to
all of their people anyone know the
answer there's one you're living in it
so the question that we ask ourselves
again which is not asked never on
television and certainly not in Congress
how does it happen
that we end up spending far far more per
capita I live 50 miles away from the
Canadian border we spend about double
what the Canadians do per capita on
health care and they cover every man
woman and child we spend almost three
times more than they do in the United
Kingdom more than we do in France
Germany and our health care outcomes in
terms of life expectancy in terms of
child infant mortality are in many cases
worse than many of these other countries
well that's the question we have to put
on the table and then the answer as to
why we are the only major country not to
guarantee health care to all through I
would hope a medicare-for-all
single-payer program the reason has
everything to do the reason has
everything to do with the power of the
insurance companies and the drug
companies and the medical equipment
suppliers they are making they love the
current system last year the top five
drug companies in America made 50
billion dollars in profit top ten drug
company executives made over three
hundred million dollars in compensation
it is a great system for them not such a
great system for ordinary Americans and
then we have got to ask ourselves and we
have some very clear language of how we
go from here to there we can create a
Medicare
for all single-payer system it will save
middle-class families money guarantee
quality care to all of our people that's
an issue we've got to put on the table
there is an issue question and again
these are questions that we need to
discuss why does our great country
United States of America have more
people in jail than any other country on
Earth right now there are a lot of
reasons why but we need a and the book
tries to do that tries to answer that
question why is it that you have a
country like China four times our size
and population a communist authoritarian
country that doesn't tolerate dissent
terribly well and we have more people in
jail than China does why is it that over
the last number of years state after
state my safe California probably your
state have been investing enormous
amounts of money in jails and
incarceration while cutting back on
education and job training for young
people
and I think most Americans though we
need reform in local police departments
around the country I was a mayor for
eight years I worked very closely with
the police Obama the average police
officer has an enormous ly difficult job
works hard and as honest it is a tough
job but we need the kind of training
which tells police officers that lethal
force is the last response not the first
response we need to be thinking about
something that is so obvious we lock
people up and then they come out of jail
I remember we did a forum on criminal
justice in Iowa and we had a couple of
guys there what had been in jail spent
time in jail and one guy said never
forget this he said the day before I was
released he had know he was going to be
released somebody came in to him and
said you're getting out of here tomorrow
here's a check for $75
good luck and then we are shocked that
so many people who go to jail end up
going back into the environment that got
him in jail in the first place we're
shocked by the high rate of recidivism
and it is clear to everybody there
people who are in jail need job training
they need education they need decent
housing we need to make sure that they
don't end up back in jail where we spend
fifty sixty thousand dollars a year
incarcerate them a lot more sense to
invest in housing and job training
and one of the major issues that I am
quite confident that Congress will be
dealing with after mr. Trump is
inaugurated will be immigration now in
my view when you have 11 million people
who are undocumented I believe that the
time is long overdue for comprehensive
immigration reform and a path toward
citizenship it appears that mr. Trump's
point of view is somewhat different and
this is going to be a major major
struggle but I will tell you that during
the campaign I talked to a number of
young Latino boys and girls and I talked
to kids who are tears running down their
cheeks who was scared to death that one
day after cutting out of school and
going home they were going to find that
a dad or their mother had been deported
in my view we need an immigration policy
which unites families not divides
families
[Applause]
so those are some of the issues that we
discuss in the book and the bottom line
is that for me democracy in a civilized
society is not a complicated idea what
it really means is that people come
together like we do here this evening
and we say okay what are the problems
facing the country and we may disagree
some people may think this is a problem
that I don't think is a major problem
and so forth but that's part of the
process and then we say okay these are
the problems what is the best way to go
forward and to solve them not
complicated but we do much too little of
that what campaigns are about a ripping
but there are people who make millions
of dollars you know what researching me
for the last 50 years every dumb thing
that I've ever said there's a file this
big all right it's called opposition
research guys make a lot of money doing
that peak figuring out how you can come
up with a 30-second end to destroy
somebody else how you come up with ads
that are complete and total lies right
and our job as citizens is to demand a
democracy of a higher level to not
accept that
so if there is anything I hope you get
out of the book is that I am NOT looking
back I'm looking forward I'm looking I
believe there is a will in this country
we've just got to bring people together
to create a nation in which we have an
economy that works for all of us that we
do not forget people in small rural
towns who are living in despair people
in inner cities who are in trouble that
we create an economy that works for all
of us and not just the 1% and I believe
there is a will to create a political
system in which billionaires do not buy
elections but in which we have a vibrant
democracy of one person one vote
[Applause]
so I want to thank you all for being I
think we are now going to work on some
questions which you have submitted so
how do we go from here somebody's coming
up do I hear somebody here you are thank
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you Thank You senator Sanders
for being here it this is our 33rd Miami
Book Fair and I want to thank you for
this remarkable talk that you just gave
thank you so very much
[Applause]
now what's really interesting is I
probably had maybe 300 questions and the
most interesting thing is you've
answered each and every one of them in
the talk that you gave so I'm left with
one question what is your favorite film
ya know in a more serious vein here
thinking about it what is your favorite
film thinking in in a more serious thing
the probably the question that was the
most prevalent is a question that has
been talked about all throughout the
book fair and that is given everything
you talk about in all the important
issues that you mentioned the quit and
given the political reality we find
ourselves in now what can we all do I
think we can and I know everybody works
hard I mean one of the things about
America knows a lot of people I saw this
on the campaign trail people are
exhausted you know people work at long
hours mom works dad works that have
enough time with the kids
marriages are suffering as a result but
I think in these difficult times we are
going to have to rethink a relationship
to public life and to politics and to
figure out ways and for each person it
will be different each community it will
be different but what I said a moment
ago is what I believe is that when
people stand together around any and all
issues your voices will be heard you
will have an impact you cannot be
ignored cannot be politicians are many
things they're not dumb and if they see
for example give you an example just one
example give you a million a couple of
years ago virtually all Republicans in
the Congress not all but virtually all
and some Democrats wanted to cut social
security a number of us worked very hard
with senior organizations around the
country I was able to submit a petition
with I believe over two million names on
it
all over this country people stood up
disabled veterans stood up seniors that
are people with disabilities that up and
said you cannot cut Social Security I
was just not a TV show a few months ago
an hour ago and a woman called into the
show and said I'm scared to death a
barely making it now and they're talking
about cutting Social Security we stopped
those cuts and in fact during the
campaign the discussion was on how we
expand Social Security we did it because
millions of people became involved in
the process now more than ever you got
to pick your fights you know not
everybody's gonna be out on the streets
every day you got to pick your fights
and figure how you can be effective but
think about it differently than you did
yesterday you can play a role in
transforming this country I believe that
if this country the people of this
country tell mr. Trump sorry we are
going to transform our energy system
because we have a moral responsibility
for our kids and our grandchildren to
protect this planet that's what you're
going to do we can do that but in all of
those things we've got to be very smart
we got to understand that we're taking
on people with incredible amounts of
money people know how to manipulate the
system people who own the media puffs up
but we have the responsibility to do
just that right now is there a resource
that you know that people here in Miami
can tap into to find out which groups
they ought to be able to give their
support to whether it's time or finances
there are a million different
organizations out there I don't want to
mention one and not the other but by the
way as I mentioned also earlier I hope
to make I mean the Democratic Party is
not that resource today
I hope tomorrow to make it that
resources I hope it to make it the party
that all of you feel comfortable about
being in and and I know that you have
supported representative Ellison to be
the head of the DMV could you talk a
little bit about your strengths you know
as I said earlier in politics you have
to make fundamental decisions and the
decisions really are not complicated
which side are you on are you on the
side of the 1% that is doing
phenomenally well the 1% to make an
extraordinary amount of campaign
contributions are you on their side or
are you going to be on the side of
working people and families today that
are struggling on just to keep their
heads above water are you going to be on
the side of the homeless veteran who's
sleeping out on the streets in Miami or
in Vermont whose side are you on and I
hope the Democratic Party finally makes
that decision and when they do I think
they're going to find millions of people
getting involved and I think they're
going to turn around politics in this
country and become once again the
dominant party but they should be
someone someone from the audience points
out that former representative Dingell
from Michigan tweeted something out of
hate views or tweet that he tweeted
something out and he said forget the
basket the deplorable Czar finding their
way into the cabinet how in a real
politic way do you feel the Senate might
go and some of these overalls of laurels
I really dislike that expression very
much
um look no question no question that
some of Trump supporters are racists and
sexist and homophobes no question about
that but that is not the majority of
those people and I think you know one of
the things that happens in this country
is that people who sit down with a $200
bottle of wine and a $500 dinner have
not a clue about what's going on in the
real world in this country about the
stuff cream in the paint and the people
who get their hands dirty or may not
have a college education you know my
parents didn't go to college doesn't
make them deplorable we got to reach out
and they have got to understand that you
know that a party Republican party that
wants to give tax breaks to billionaires
and many of them want to cut their
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
that's not their party so how how as a
senator and how I know how we as
citizens can probably move but do you
have given given what we've seen so far
from the president-elect how do we make
sure that we protect the First Amendment
for a free press the First Amendment
rights for a free press and what do we
do about it not just the First Amendment
it's how do you protect all of our
rights which maybe come under assault
and the answer is
if people are strong and are prepared to
fight back we will win if not the future
may be somewhat bleak so my message is
that no matter what the issue is whether
it's constitutional rights whether it is
the economy whether it is the attack on
immigrants or on minorities we have got
to mobilize our people and stand firm
defend the Constitution and make certain
that our people get involved so that we
create a government and economy that
works everybody and not just the 1% so
there's nothing easy it takes a lot of
work but again I want to at a time when
many people are depressed politically
think back think back think back to when
some of us was still alive of the kind
of segregation and racism that existed
in parts of this country think about the
role that women were forced to play a
hundred years ago people struggled and
they won and they made progress that was
true then that is true today
and and without putting you on the spot
the next most popular question was will
you run in 2020 not a good not my wife
was said that I'm quoting her it's not
the right question alright because we
got a struggle tomorrow we don't want to
get hung up when I say this in all
humility and I thank so much so you feel
support not about me we've got a
struggle tomorrow our job is to educate
to organize to mobilize people four
years from now is a very long time we
got other things to worry about
today
[Applause]
you talk about universal healthcare and
it's something that so many of us
believe in what do you think the
straightest path to get that is at this
point I think the problem lies in a
corrupt campaign finance system and that
the first thing we have got to do is
overturn Citizens United
and in my view move to public funding of
Elections what we also have got to do
and it's worrying to me very much and
it's directly related to healthcare or
the environment or anything else is we
have to pay a lot of attention and fight
back against voter suppression there are
cowardly Republican governors all over
this country who are afraid of free open
and democratic elections and they're
trying to make it harder for young
people for old people for people of
color to participate in the political
process and we've got to resist that and
move toward a nation in which everybody
18 years of age or older was a citizen
has the right to vote end of discussion
you know in it and when we do that we
will be able when we do that we will be
able to take on the insurance companies
and the drug companies they are the
impediments to a national health care
system they want to maintain a health
care system in which they can make
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
in profit and our job is to tell them
that's a function of health care the
health care system is to provide quality
care to all people in the most
cost-effective way not to make drug
companies and insurance companies make
billions of dollars a year profit
and and if interesting because the next
question was someone from the audience
pointing out that Florida has 1.7
million former felons whose folks were
suppressed in Florida absolutely this is
a Florida I think is one of the worst
states in that regard in Vermont in
Vermont what our state has done and a
few other states have done we have done
what was right and that is we said that
if you served your time in jail you paid
your debt to society when you get out
you have your democratic rights
but when we talk about voter suppression
that is certainly one of the areas that
we have got to focus on if you served
your time you have the right to regain
your ability to participate in vote
thank you do you do you expect big
fights in the Senate over the Supreme
Court nominations after I know the
answer I think to that but how how are
the answers of course we don't know who
the nominee is you can't it's premature
to answer it but I think it is fair to
say that yeah that would be the case and
I think it is based on it's not only
what we fear who might be then I'm the
earliest of politics of the person who
might be the nominee but we come into
that with the reality that Republicans
in the Senate their leadership ignored
the Constitution and refused to even
allow for hearings of President Obama's
nominee now all of you know the
Constitution is not ambiguous about this
the president has the right to nominate
somebody and the Senate has the right to
hold hearings of determined whether the
person is qualified to it and the
Republicans said Obama is President we
don't want to have any hearings at all
so I think that with that background
probably mr. Trump's nominee will not
win the most enthusiastic response from
the Democratic caucus
this is the way some of the much younger
folks in the audience are feeling
someone this question comes from a
thirteen year old what can we do to keep
trump under control I think it's a very
interesting question well again it mean
all of these questions and trust me it's
not just people in this room what
thirteen year old kids it is people all
over this country are worried and the
answer again I don't mean to be beating
a dead horse here is that we have to
rethink our role in our democracy and
that is we if there are actions that are
taken that we think are unconstitutional
or simply bad or unfair we have got to
stand up mobilize and fight back that's
called democracy we can do that and
that's what we have got to do maybe just
a few more okay I will just take two
more questions and the first one will be
can we take you to dinner this comes
from including Jane this is from Jen and
Lily in the audience in Vermont when we
do meetings like that we often have food
so maybe next time it's like some food
we could all have dinner together but
but actually more serious question is
what is your feeling about the electoral
college as well as I began my remarks
Hillary Clinton got we think in
California it takes forever for them to
count those I don't know why that so but
it does but we think she will have ended
up with a million and a half to two
million more votes to mr. Trump in a
democracy one might assume that if you
get more votes than your opponent you
win that's not the case now this
happened obviously with Al Gore and
she's something about the state of
Florida about that
um alright so that's number one am i
comfortable with the fact that somebody
wins more votes than her opponent and is
not inaugurated I am uncomfortable with
that number two maybe as a politician I
see this more we have 50 states in this
country and every one of these states
has serious problems and their people
have needs but what has happened in the
last number of elections everybody knows
there are 1516 battleground states
Florida being one of them so you in this
states or a whole lot of mrs. Clinton
these are a lot of mr. Trump because
everybody here knew it was a
battleground state and ended up but a
couple of points about same thing with
Iowa same thing with Michigan
Pennsylvania Ohio Wisconsin etc
meanwhile guess what there are 35 other
states in this country who very rarely
see a candidate for president who very
rarely have their issues being discussed
there needs things assessed there's
something wrong with that we are a
nation of some 320 million people living
in 50 Cent's politics and all due
respect to Florida and the other 15
states should not just be about 15 or 16
states you should be about 50 states and
all about
you know you you've brought and
energized so many people that I think
the last question you know to ask
particularly after a very difficult week
of hearing so many speakers be so
fearful and and and concerned about
where the future lies what hope can you
give us tonight given all that you've
seen all that you know and all of that I
can give you a lot of hope I mean I and
I think again this country you know if
you study our own history they've been
very very dark periods I mean I don't
have to relate to anybody in this room
you know what
you know people this country way back
when have done the Native Americans
african-americans Latinos you know the
struggles of the gay community and so
forth and so on
and yet over a period of time people
came together and they made life better
you know 100 years ago your children
working in factories losing their
fingers and workers said no that came to
one public education free public
education didn't come out of nowhere it
came because people fought for it so
what I'm saying is yeah these are talk
to dark times you have that top you know
I'm thinking back right now I remember
that I went to an event in Vermont a
couple of years ago and they showed a
film I don't know if any of you saw it
probably did December 8 1941
what was that remember that was about
that was the day after Pearl Harbor and
President Roosevelt goes before Congress
to declare war on Japan and a wild later
on Germany at that moment the military
of this country was not prepared to
fight wars in the east and was in the
West we didn't have the resources to do
that and yet a united country two and a
half years later for all intents and
purposes by the end of 1943 the war was
essentially what we were producing
incredible amounts of tanks and planes
and guns a United the military was
extraordinary
a united America took on powerful forces
in Europe powerful forces in Asia and at
three years four
is one the war so yes I understand that
people are distressed I understand that
but I would say two things don't lose
faith in our capabilities that's number
one we have come through very difficult
times in the past and number two despair
is not an option
you don't have
and I want somebody throws their hands
up and says you know I'm giving up you
don't have that right because it's not
just about you this country is not just
about you it's about your children it's
about the future of this planet you want
to give up you know what that means
you're going to doom this planet
literally as a result of climate change
you don't have the moral right to do
that so I think we've got to rethink
things and maybe worry a little bit less
about football I know I know I am
treading on very controversial areas and
maybe pay a little bit more attention to
the issues impacting our children and
our parents and our families and stand
together that's what you know when I use
the phrase political revolution that's
what it means it's not that I have an 86
point program it means the you've got so
decides the best way forward what does
it mean here in Florida you would know
what climate change can do to this very
city are you going to allow an expansion
of fossil fuel in this country to make a
bad situation worse
I hope not and you got to figure out the
best way to put pressure on your elected
officials on Washington figure out ways
to do that and many other issues as well
so now I am not you know I am ready for
a fight I hope all of you are ready for
a fight that's what we've got to do
thank you all very much
senator bernie sanders thank you so much
[Applause]
you